this one will wake to define what a
sequence is right paddle did formula
then the one starting with an arbor meet
one a recursion right we can have a way
of stating a stating the sequence HTM
depending on the prior turns so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna say look I have to
start with a term I have to define
generally the first time sometimes
depending on the sequence may be a
couple of terms I'm just going to define
just like I have for the previous ones
the first term I'm just gonna call that
a but from then on I don't need anything
else to define the rest of the terms
right the nth term is just going to be
in terms of the previous term which is
TN minus 1 how do I get to the next term
I just add the difference right I just
added in its good morning okay watch out
why is hey hey first lit up first Hood
and then you just add one love the
difference in that mix the next is so
okay now before I put this last bit of
because we have that's always you need
to define am a sequence right let me
point out a couple of things minor minor
points as soon as I say this right I'm
talking about numbers a and date right
and II can be any real numbers we like
so fact I'm just gonna put this on the
site because this condition will go
across the road a and D to be a real
numbers we like okay but we sequence
their actual numbers I'm writing it here
because that's I've introduced a B so I
better know what they're talking about
a is the first term and D is the common
difference but once I get down to here
and I'm talking about a third novel
what's the third number that I introduce
its n right it's N and can't just be any
real number for a sequence right there
are only some numbers it can take for
instance I could have the first term
second term he's such a be the sequence
well as a one and a half turn right or a
negative one term
so what condition what family of numbers
does n below it won't sue the positive
numbers and it's the integers right
because I can't have fractions or
anything like that
so I would write that like so the Z
indicates integers comes from the German
words all for counting and the plus
indicates it's positive uh yeah that
kind of is implied in that the integers
are you know negative 3 negative 2
negative 1 0 1 2 3 and so on and then
when I need a plus that limits it to
wanted to the right okay okay now one
last thing which we're going to add on
to this table that's why these rows down
here a bit longer I can use one of the
reasons why this recursive definition
which seem to be awkward like why would
you do that um for any other sequences
like a platform Fibonacci you don't need
to do that this is probably a far more
elegant way to do it if I want to find
the hundredth term which we will in a
couple of minutes okay clearly this is a
faster way to do it than this because
you've got to work out all 99 prior
terms if you want to use the recursive
definition the recursive definition is
really useful one particular thing which
is testing okay how do you test whether
a sequence is an AP or not because
there's an infinite number of different
sequences out there and they're not all
ATP's I'm going to use where the
recursive definition right you state it
two ways firstly what I want is that if
I say take the nth term and subtract the
previous one so I'm appealing to my
recursive definition right if I subtract
the previous term for any of my terms I
should get that same common difference
do you see that this is literally just a
restatement off the recursive definition
right so in some ways the recursive
definition is my test I'm gonna had a
bit more language for you right I want
this to be true not just for like you
know people want pair of terms I want to
be true for all of the terms of all
right
so for instance if I added this
everything's still fine right all of
these differences still three but if I
had a turn like say just saying that
right suddenly my secrets is broken
right I have a whole bunch of pairs of
terms that do this the common difference
is three but then I have just one pair
of terms where it doesn't work so I only
need one pair this is proof by
counterexample
it's not a pay anymore if I have this
100 in there okay so I need this proper
to be property to be true
here's a submit single for you for all
values every single value on em right
remembering that n is positive integers
so I want this to be true for all of the
terms that you've given me okay I could
write but that's just a quick way to
right now in reality in practice right
you would usually get this many terms
how many terms do you need to establish
they happen
just three right so 99% of the time you
will have exactly three terms like
that's all I need to define it so tell
me you tend to see therefore how many
times do I need to do this how many
pairs of numbers do I have I have two
pairs of numbers right I have I have
this pair right and then I have this
pair right so all I have to do is make
sure those two pairs line up in other
words if I do turn to take away two one
that's the first pair that should be
able to turn three take away turn two
that's the second pair so this is
stating generally what should be true if
you get like a hundred terms you won't
but if you had any arbitrary number of
terms you should be able to take the
difference and always get the same
constant out but more realistically
speaking you're generally at 3m and they
ask you to test just need to show that
these two pairs are equal to one another